Das hier sind die Vertreter von 13
mächtigen Firmen, unter anderem BMW,
Shell und Total. Wie jedes Jahr treffen
sie sich auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum in
Davos. 2017 entsteht hier der Hydrogen
Council, eine Wasserstoff-Lobbygruppe,
die dafür sorgt, dass das fossile Geschäft der Öl-
und Gaskonzerne länger am Leben bleibt. Und
das, unter anderem, durch Wasserstoffautos.
Wait what?! Wasserstoffautos sind doch eigentlich
eine super Lösung. Wasserstoff ist das häufigste
Element im Universum und er kann quasi
überall klimaneutral hergestellt werden.
Wasserstoffautos sind in ein paar Minuten
betankt, haben eine Reichweite, die man
sonst nur vom Verbrenner kennt und stoßen beim
Fahren ausschließlich sauberen Wasserdampf aus.
Aber was, wenn ich dir sage, dass
diese Wasserstoff-Lobby jährlich
allein in der EU über 75 Millionen Euro
ausgibt, damit wir all das glauben?
Dass es neben dem Hydrogen Council noch
zahlreiche andere Allianzen von Big Oil,
Autoherstellern und der Chemiebranche
gibt, die Wasserstoff greenwashen? Und
dass es einen großen Haken gibt, wenn
wir überall auf Wasserstoff setzen?
Wie umweltfreundlich ist das Wasserstoffauto
wirklich? Und was haben Shell, BP und Co. davon,
wenn du daran glaubst? Genau darum
geht es jetzt in diesem Video.
Ein Disclaimer zu Beginn: Wasserstoff an
sich brauchen wir in Zukunft auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt viele coole Technologien, die darauf
setzen und super sinnvoll sind, aber in diesem
Video fokussieren wir uns auf den Einsatz von
Wasserstoff in Autos – und der ist nicht sinnvoll.
Ok, wovon reden wir hier eigentlich? Statt
einer Batterie haben Wasserstoffautos einen
Wasserstofftank und eine Brennstoffzelle,
die die chemische Energie des Wasserstoffs
in elektrische Energie für den Elektromotor
umwandelt. Sie sind also auch E-Autos. Fürs
Beschleunigen und die Rekuperation –
also die Rückgewinnung von Energie beim
Bremsen – besitzen Wasserstoffautos
aber auch noch einen kleinen Akku.
Weil gasförmiger Wasserstoff eine geringe Dichte
hat, muss man ihn komprimieren. Für Pkw auf
700 bar, also über 200 Mal den Druck eines
Autoreifens! Dadurch haben Wasserstoffautos
tendenziell eine höhere Reichweite und können
viel schneller tanken als Batterieelektroautos.
Aber: Wie viele Wasserstoff-Autos habt ihr in den
letzten 6 Monaten gesehen? Hier und da vielleicht,
aber wahrscheinlich nicht ansatzweise so
oft wie Batterieelektroautos – und das
zeigt sich auch in den Zulassungszahlen:
Zwischen Januar und September wurden in
Deutschland über 2 Millionen Pkw neu zugelassen.
Davon waren über 387.000 Batterieelektroautos,
aber nur 252 waren Wasserstoffautos! Nicht
252.000, sondern 252 insgesamt! Woran liegt das?
Ein verbessertes Ladenetz, hohe
Ladegeschwindigkeiten und bessere Akkutechnologie
machen den Reichweitenvorteil von Wasserstoffautos
schon kleiner. Aber Lobbyisten und Politiker
plädieren für “Technologieoffenheit”. Damit ist
gemeint, dass keiner Technologie ein Vorsprung in
der Förderung gegeben werden soll. An und für sich
richtig, Forschung soll natürlich ergebnisoffen
sein, aber NGOs und Medien kritisieren, dass der
Begriff auch genutzt wird, um Technologien wie
E-Fuels und Wasserstoff in der Diskussion
zu halten. Dabei ist der “Kampf” zwischen
E- und Wasserstoff-Autos von Industrie-Seite
eigentlich schon längst entschieden. Gewinner
ist ganz klar die Batterie, und nur wenige
Hersteller arbeiten noch an Wasserstoffautos.
In Deutschland gibt es zum Beispiel auch nur zwei
Serien-Modelle mit Wasserstoffantrieb zu
kaufen. Und der Trend geht nicht aufwärts,
sondern abwärts. Mehrere Modelle
wurden eingestellt! Durch die niedrigen
Produktionszahlen sind Wasserstoffautos
auch noch echt teuer in der Anschaffung.
Dazu kommt, dass es in Deutschland,
je nach Datenbank, zwischen 90 und
100 Wasserstofftankstellen gibt. Die
sind sinnvoll verteilt, und damit ist
Deutschland im Verhältnis zum Ausland ganz gut
abgedeckt. Trotzdem muss man lange Strecken
planen. Ohne genug Wasserstoff-Fahrzeuge
auf den Straßen lohnen sich Tankstellen
halt auch nicht. Und ohne Tankstellen
kauft man kein Fahrzeug. Anders als bei
Ladepunkten ist die Zahl über die letzten
Jahre aber auch nicht wirklich gewachsen.
Aber das ist der Individualverkehr. Im Lastverkehr
hieß es lange, dass es kaum eine Alternative
zum Wasserstoff geben wird. Mittlerweile
gibt es aber auch schon Batterie-Modelle,
die mit einer Akkuladung 300 bis
600 Kilometer schaffen und somit
in den vorgeschriebenen Pausenplan der
Trucker passen. Experten gehen davon aus,
dass Wasserstoff nur auf langen Strecken
mit schlechter Ladeinfrastruktur eine Rolle
spielen wird, denn Batterie-Lkw sind in der
Anschaffung und im Betrieb deutlich günstiger.
Und das gilt genau so auch fürs Auto. Grüner
Wasserstoff, der mit Strom aus erneuerbaren
Quellen hergestellt wird, wird ohne Subventionen
immer teurer sein als erneuerbarer Strom direkt.
Das liegt an den Grundgesetzen der Physik.
Beim Batterieelektroauto wird die Batterie
mit Strom geladen, und der treibt den
Elektromotor an. Dabei geht Energie verloren,
zum Beispiel beim Laden oder im Motor. Insgesamt
kommen aber 70 bis 80 Prozent der Energie auf der
Straße an. Beim Wasserstoffauto gibt es auch
Strom und einen Elektromotor, aber mehrere
verlustreiche Zwischenschritte zusätzlich:
Allein schon bei der Wasserstoffherstellung
per Elektrolyse gehen etwa 30 Prozent der Energie
verloren. Dann wird der Wasserstoff komprimiert,
gekühlt und transportiert, also nochmal minus 20
bis 25 Prozent. Und in der Brennstoffzelle haben
wir sogar die größten Verluste: rund 45 Prozent.
Mit einem Wasserstoffauto braucht man also für
die gleiche Strecke zwei- bis dreimal mal so viel
Strom wie mit einem Batterieelektroauto. Und das
spiegelt sich auch im Preis wider. Ein Kilogramm
Wasserstoff, was für etwa 100 Kilometer reicht,
kostet an fast allen Tankstellen über 15 Euro,
und die sind sogar stark subventioniert! Das
ist mehr als für 7 Liter Benzin oder für 20
Kilowattstunden – selbst an der Schnellladesäule.
Schauen wir jetzt mal auf die CO2-Bilanz
der Wasserstoffmobilität. Immerhin werden
Wasserstoffautos ja als ökologische
Alternative zum E-Auto dargestellt.
Und hier hat die Lobby ganze Arbeit geleistet:
Denn ja, Wasserstoffautos mögen praktisch sein,
aber sie fallen nicht einfach vom Himmel.
Genauso wenig wie der Wasserstoff selbst.
Wegen des hohen Drucks muss der Tank aufwändig aus
kohlenstofffaserverstärktem Kunststoff
hergestellt werden. Zusammen mit der
Brennstoffzelle verursacht das ähnlich
viel CO2 wie eine mittlere E-Auto-Batterie.
Wenn das Auto dann klimaneutral läuft, wäre es
das ja aber wert. Nur ist das einfach nicht der
Fall. Um Wasserstoff herzustellen, gibt es
verschiedene Methoden: Grauer Wasserstoff
entsteht bei der sogenannten Dampf-Reformierung
aus Erdgas. Weil viele Faktoren mit einfließen,
ergeben sich je nach Szenario also etwas andere
Zahlen. Laut Umweltbundesamt entstehen aber von
der Erdgasförderung bis zum Wasserstofftransport
pro Kilogramm Wasserstoff etwa 16 Kilogramm
CO2-Äquivalente. Die IEA spricht wiederum
von bis zu 27 Kilogramm im Extremfall.
Grüner Wasserstoff entsteht, wenn Wasser
mit erneuerbarem Strom in Wasserstoff und
Sauerstoff gespalten wird – das ist die sogenannte
Elektrolyse. Er ist also potenziell klimaneutral,
wenn der Transport klimaneutral ist und der
Strom sonst nicht genutzt worden wäre. Grüner
Strom – und damit auch grüner Wasserstoff –
ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den steigenden
Bedarf CO2-arm zu decken, aber immer noch
rar. 2022 wurden nur etwa 0,1 Prozent des
Wasserstoffs mittels Elektrizität hergestellt.
Und grüner Wasserstoff ist nur ein Teil davon,
weil ja nicht aller Strom erneuerbar ist!
Theoretisch kann grüner Wasserstoff auch aus
Überschussstrom entstehen. Der wird allerdings
relativ teuer und auch einfach nicht ausreichend
sein. Also grünen Wasserstoff importieren? Auch
das wird nicht leicht, denn Pipelines gibt es
noch nicht ausreichend, und der Transport per
Schiff oder Tankwagen ist aufwändig und teuer.
Außerdem müssen sich auch die Produktionsländer
selbst mit Wasserstoff und Strom versorgen.
Während viele Branchen also auf grünen Wasserstoff
hoffen, der in nächster Zeit aber knapp sein wird,
bringt die Lobby eine vermeintlich
super saubere Brückentechnologie auf:
Blauen Wasserstoff. Warum der aber gar
nicht so sauber ist, klären wir gleich.
Das heißt: Damit Wasserstoffmobilität
umweltfreundlich sein kann, brauchen wir
grünen Wasserstoff. Dafür haben wir aber noch
keine ausreichenden Produktionskapazitäten,
er ist schwierig zu transportieren und wird
aufgrund der Ineffizienz teurer sein als Strom.
Und vor allem: Es gibt viele andere Branchen, die
auch auf Wasserstoff setzen. Deshalb sollte der
Wasserstoff vor allem dort eingesetzt werden,
wo er besonders viel CO2 einspart und nicht zu
ersetzen ist. Ein Beispiel dafür ist die
Stahlindustrie, aber eben nicht das Auto.
Dazu kommt: Der heute an Tankstellen verkaufte
Wasserstoff ist nicht grün. Darum vergleichen
wir Benzin mit grauem Wasserstoff: Für 100
Kilometer braucht man ungefähr ein Kilogramm,
das also 16 Kilogramm CO2-Emissionen
verursacht. Für die CO2-Menge kann man
auch 5 Liter Benzin herstellen, transportieren
und verbrennen. Wenn man nur auf das schaut,
was aus dem Auspuff kommt, sind es
sogar fast 7 Liter. Unterm Strich
gibt es daher kaum einen Emissionsvorteil für
Wasserstoffautos mit fossilem Wasserstoff.
Okay, und was war jetzt mit dem blauen
Wasserstoff? Der wird eigentlich genauso
gewonnen wie grauer, mit dem Unterschied, dass
bei der Dampf-Reformierung 60 bis 90 Prozent des
CO2 abgeschieden und unterirdisch gespeichert
werden. Das klingt zwar richtig schlau und super
umweltfreundlich und wird auch so vermarktet,
aber … die Emissionen entstehen nicht nur bei
der Dampf-Reformierung an sich, sondern
auch beim Erdgastransport oder durch den
Energieaufwand bei der Herstellung. Dadurch
verursacht ein Kilogramm blauer Wasserstoff
trotzdem 12 bis 13 Kilogramm CO2-Äquivalente,
und ist damit kaum weniger schädlich als grauer!
Ein Teil der Emissionen wird durch Methan
verursacht, das auf kurze Zeit gesehen sogar
noch deutlich klimaschädlicher ist als CO2. Dazu
könnten wir eigentlich ein ganzes Video machen.
Wenn Lobbyorganisationen grauen Wasserstoff
greenwashen und für blauen Wasserstoff lobbyieren,
dann ist das nicht aus Umweltbewusstsein. Wenn
sie damit Erfolg haben und sich Wasserstoff im
Individualverkehr durchsetzt, sind wir für lange
Zeit, bis es genug grünen Wasserstoff gibt,
abhängig von fossilen Rohstoffen. Und wenn das
nicht klappt, hat die Lobby zumindest Verwirrung
gestiftet und die Elektrifizierung verzögert. Ich
würde sogar behaupten, dass das ihr primäres Ziel
ist, weil sie ganz genau wissen, dass Wasserstoff
im Individualverkehr keinen Sinn ergibt.
Die IEA, das Wuppertal Institut, der Nationale
Wasserstoffrat – Experten sehen Wasserstoffautos
nicht in großen Mengen auf den Straßen, Quellen
dazu findet ihr wie immer bei uns unter dem Video.
Es gibt einfach viele andere Einsatzbereiche von
Wasserstoff, in denen er wirklich unverzichtbar
ist, wo er einen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
leistet, statt Klimaschutz zu verhindern.
Trotzdem sagen viele, sie warten aufs
Wasserstoffauto und holen sich deshalb
kein E-Auto. Aber erstens müsste man schon
lange nicht mehr warten, sondern könnte
sich längst eins kaufen – wenn man es ernst
meint. Und zweitens ist das eine Entscheidung,
die nicht umweltfreundlicher oder günstiger
sein wird als ein Batterieelektroauto
oder noch besser gar kein Auto zu
kaufen. Wer E-Autos schlecht macht
und für "Technologieoffenheit" plädiert,
unterstützt also, bewusst oder unbewusst,
die Öl-und Gas-Lobby dabei, ihr altes
Geschäftsmodell länger am Leben zu erhalten.
# Werbung
Wie gerade gesagt: Das beste Auto ist gar kein
Auto. Und wenn ihr denkt, “Das geht bei mir nicht,
der Supermarkt ist viel zu weit weg” oder ihr
vielleicht einfach eure Autofahrten reduzieren
wollt, dann hilft euch HelloFresh. HelloFresh
liefert euch die Zutaten fürs Kochen einfach
nach Hause. Anstatt dass viele Leute
jeweils einzeln mit ihrem tonnenschweren
Auto zum Supermarkt fahren, fährt also
ein – meist elektrischer – Lieferwagen
von HelloFresh ganz viele Wohnungen ab
und stellt euch das Essen vor die Tür.
Und das sogar direkt in den richtigen Mengen.
Ich muss mir also nicht für ein einzelnes Gericht
Zutaten kaufen, von denen ich dann am Ende wieder
etwas wegschmeißen muss, weil es übrig bleibt.
Für uns bei Doktor Whatson hat Kochen
und gemeinsames Essen einen besonderen
Stellenwert. Wir bekochen uns abwechselnd in
unseren Mittagspausen und versuchen uns immer
gegenseitig mit neuen Ideen zu überraschen. Bei
HelloFresh kann man ganz einfach mit der App aus
einem breiten Angebot wählen und man muss sich
dank der mitgelieferten Rezepte keine Gedanken
über die Zubereitung machen. Damit
bleibt mehr Zeit zum Kochen und Essen.
Wenn ihr HelloFresh also auch
einmal ausprobieren wollt,
dann nutzt unseren Code “HELLODOKTORWHATSON”
und gönnt euch ganze 120€ Neukunden-Rabatt.
Außerdem spart ihr euch auch noch
die Versandkosten für eure erste
Box. Den Link zu HelloFresh findet
ihr auch in der Videobeschreibung.
# Werbung Ende
In diesem Sinne, bleibt neugierig,
bleibt kritisch. Euer Cedric.